all right star trek convention is back
at the rio this weekend that's right the
show runs through sunday trekkies can
expect to get photo ops a costume
contest and celebrity appearances
there's still some tickets available but
you can't get them online or you can't
get them online so you'll have to buy
them at the show organizers warn they
may sell out we have a lot of trekkie
fans here there's a lot of tricky fans
everywhere yes live long and prosper
speaking of from we go from now the
final frontier to the old flamingo a new
exhibit is opening at the mob museum
today focused on bugsy siegel and the
old flamingo this exhibit dives deep
into the past of the original hotel
which opened back in 1946 and evidently
organized crime was involved in growing
las vegas back in the day i'm not sure
about that anyway and i think it's maybe
called the mob i think there's an entire
museum dedicated to that and that's
where this exhibit will take place of
little artifacts from bugsy siegel the
flingo et cetera you can spend hours in
the my museum it's a fantastic place
it's pretty cool and i hear that robert
conrad getting back to the star trek
exhibit is going to make an appearance
he's 90 years old robert conrad yes but
what did he have to do with star trek no
no isn't that who who was on star trek
no what are you talking about william
robert was the guy with the batteries
sorry he was in the wild wild west
sorry which although we're breaking all
sorts of ground gene roddenberry you
were taking a giant leap there he he
called a star trek uh a wild west to the
stars oh okay wagon train to the stars
so that's where you were coming i'm
going robert conrad wait a minute
william shatner
don't you know that i'm talking about
i'm sorry sorry
that was informative and informational
let's move on let's move on to weather
sharing